now walk up to this video playing one
good one good one good one good from
Finland and turn let's see click night
after keeping my options open okay let's
do something else play the color you can
play the color with c3 on with be 3r
Dorothy 3 version this is some not super
aggressive opening of course but it's a
also not particularly bad it's um just
the sammies laughs with colors reversed
and the same it's lava so very
respectable opening of course so I'm
just preparing a form has set up with
Bishop d6 and 97's who I uncommon maybe
he's wondering if he can guess all yeah
he decided that he can castle and the
great gift Bishop h7 is not working
probably his right if you look at this
take 95 check King to g6 Queen g4
there's f5 and I cannot go to g3 so when
there's no attack the idea was to play
for anyway the question is should i do
it now or should I take on c5 first I'll
take first it's probably load the
unplayable I spent far too much time to
get this normal position but this is not
exactly new my games so the lighter has
got a good post term understand Knight
to f4 sn1 idea should I go to be three
it's not a great square now but I need
to cover a form and
get pieces developed came should I play
yeah I need to get going Queenie to
maybe Bishop g5 roop do you want
something like that quick development he
could play night afore him getting the
bishops but it's um it's it's quite a
time waster interesting
hmm didn't really expect that move it's
not bad from him I take here he might
yeah he might take here and play 95
again nope he just recaptured
interesting
yeah the queen is not ideally placed
here obviously
and that's not comfortable at all this
has various good more special g-form and
things like that
can i play Bishop f4 maybe night d3 i'm
taking on d6 first and if you place rook
e8 i just go push up g 3 yeah i think
this might be possible it all looks a
bit shaky and I also have no pressure on
the isolated pawn so it's a it's not
great probably not i'm not substantially
worse or anything I don't think so but
it feels like black is comfortable ok i
hope i can play that and this doesn't
have any substantial drawback
right has it has again just play takes
on d3 and play but should be too
mmm f3 I just takes on f3 okay
Dec can just take it should be too
maybe he's got something better you know
oops he didn't do that okay let's let's
go eat too yeah now I'm perfectly okay
again got blockade on d4 and nothing
much hanging check
yeah of course he's got the bishops but
why this white is obviously very
solitary um I can even try a bit to play
for an edge maybe here the exchange I
obviously welcome and I want to put the
bishop on d4 anyway the bishop is better
on d4 than the night the knight on d4
it's nicely placed but it's better to
have the bishop down and then remove the
night maybe two III so that it attacks
d5 and supports further advance I still
don't mind this is a trade at all
fy5 let's be idea
so this was this was the whole point of
this um Wow here 34 probably too
ambitious but maybe I can play can
threaten g4g for enter King King thou
probably not okay black resigns oops why
did I overlooked something
and maybe he needed to leave or or
accidentally resigned it happened to me
before yeah but I'm a bit confused yep
if maybe he had to leave or something
and thought all right what the heck is
just the game probably something like
this yeah I prefer white a bit but it's
not not the end of the world yeah of
course hehe just could have played
Bishop e2 and and I'm a goner Jack oops
no this was wrong he just wish would be
to and and it's basically basically
although I had overlooked this yeah
right here this position felt a bit
uncomfortable to me but maybe the whole
problem and ok this was a blunder
obviously but cam probably a here yeah
this is ok this is ok now and then that
I can can safely and move the Queen away
from the e-file it will probably do
something like that and then let's say
this one and this is about equal I guess
black ass active and shouldn't have a
problem with the isolated pawn can maybe
maybe you get something similar to the
check to the to the game something like
this yeah this is okay for black he's
active enough I never win the d5 pawn
yeah and of course he could have just
taken here taking the exchange with this
end and just win it I mean the problem
is i can take here but i'm activating
his rooks so this is probably my it's
not yeah
like is winning but it's it's it's
actually not that easy because I get the
night to deform and then something like
this I can try to just yeah hang on a
while here it's not that easy to break
down but it should be a win in the long
run okay thanks for watching